voilà je peux cliquer sur tours je
saisis juku une adresse je saisis la
durée de la balade et en quelques clics
voici une proposition de promenade à
vélo dans un cercle de 10 km autour
d'une adresse indiquée par l'utilisateur
et pour une durée que le cycliste a lui
même fixé ce site internet baptisé dans
mon rayon point fr n'est qu'une
extension de la toute première
application française de géolocalisation
exclusivement dédié au vélo dans l'adn
de géo vélo ça toujours été de proposer
des itinéraires adaptés à la pratique du
vélo avec la particularité du type de
vélo donc est-ce qu'on a un vélo à
assistance électrique est ce qu'on est
plutôt en vtt qu'on peut emprunter plus
de petits chemins
donc on va vraiment prendre tout ça en
compte un gêneur
je vais lancer boucle ça nous mène vers
sonde est très bien c'est parti pour
profiter en tout lieu et à tout moment
des conseils avisés du site il suffit de
disposer d'un smartphone et de se
laisser guider en route si l'itinéraire
ne vous satisfait plus un simple clic
permet de générer un nouveau parcours
l'intérêt de cet ajout c'est permettre à
l'utilisateur de calculer des boucles
autour de shenley autour de son lieu de
travail
assez simplement oui moi je n'utilise en
plus j'ai la chance d'habiter dans un
papa forcément la ville donc du coup de
pouvoir avoir des routes qui sont
sympathiques autour de chez moi je ne
connaissais pas forcément d'ailleurs
avant l' annonce de la fin prochaine de
la limitation des déplacements à 10km
n'entamera pas le succès de
l'application
les amoureux du vélo sont de plus en
plus nombreux et le site continuera de
proposer des sorties pour petits
promeneurs et pour grands aventuriers